I'm like ready to flip the table all the
Australian guys I follow they're just
like literally always at the beach like
in a speedo like drinking and they all
have like a tabs and it's insane you've
got to like really get the bottom melted
into the bread you have to be really
careful with how much Vegemite be put on
them and this might be too much it's
like an argument here with Americans
like do you put the jelly on first you
put the peanut butter on first what
you're supposed to do is put the peanut
butter as the first layer on both slices
and then you put the jelly because then
the jelly doesn't make the bread soggy
I'm gonna show you why you put the jelly
on first okay so this is easily wipeable
onto the next piece of bread you clean
off your utensil on okay
so I just sort of tuck in oh my god this
looks like so hectic I think the whole
thing whoa I'm intrigued I was just
getting ready to say this actually
pretty good but I was mostly to butter
the bread and the butter with the slight
Vegemite is is good this is strong yeah
I'm glad you like that I really did but
they're both good for different reasons
yeah yeah totally is probably gonna be
the most like acceptable choice but like
that's the right I made it's pretty good
I think
this is a Mylo which I think it's like a
it's like a chocolate flavored malt
drink this is so like not how you'd have
Milo so Milo is like in a can and it's
powder usually you make it with like
fresh milk so this will be interesting
this is you ho I love how this says
chocolate drink this is a classic I
Deborah drinking this as a kid for sure
so you can't go wrong with that it
doesn't really taste chocolaty yeah this
is good yeah get around this oh my god
are you crazy I'm like wanting to get
like yeah I think this is good as well
not a fan of either of this but to me it
tastes more like a coffee drinks you
know I'm saying like guys like it more
like a coffee Erte Steve knows no poppy
here I'll I think I like this one better
I like this one better like I think I
mean if I had to choose I'm gonna go
with the usual yeah I think so as well
so now we're gonna compare on breakfast
cereals okay and I've got weet-bix I
think their nutritional I think they're
made of like oats and stuff I'm confused
because to me they look like Ronaldo
pars just in a cereal bowl there was
always like a bit of a competition to
see how many weight because people could
have so everyone would like want to like
have eight but I was a really fat kid so
I never I was more aligned with that as
a kid but have you heard of Lucky Charms
before no I haven't I'm really excited
for you bro I am as well
that looks great these are fruit loops
on crack so I'm supposed to eat this
with a spoon these are about 100 percent
ebizo itas like some blueberries in here
or something yeah yeah fresh it up very
good yeah good I mean it's like healthy
I feel like if you put like the bananas
in there being a lot better yeah these
are really good it's like candy this
isn't as good as what I thought that
this is just like pure sugar which is
like Americans mascot I'd pick Lucky
Charms actually I think really yeah I
think I would pick this but Jeff wanna
put some like berries or stuff on it I
think if I ate it for breakfast I like
feel good for rest of the day
so this is the Australian iced coffee
and so this has coffee milk and ice
cream in it so if I ordered an iced
coffee at a cafe or wherever this is
what it would look like there's nothing
there's no calories in it look it just
gets you jacked up I'm done honestly I
was young to be a lot a lot sweeter
where you say ice cream I thought it was
gonna be like super super ice cream this
is like a regular mom I was like I was
making a milkshake
this is like oh this is good coffee
today oh that's good it's not - I
screaming I think this is the only
example where the Australian alternative
has more sugar than the American this is
yeah how I would have coffee at home
Oasis changed my life bring this to
America this is a staple this is like
part of my life
this is she's cute but she's just not an
everyday type of girl personally I'd go
for this one but I understand the appeal
yeah I prefer this one to tall she's got
me
so Australia breakfast compared to us I
thought it was for the most part a lot
less sugary I liked the PB&J so we are
improving American Australian relations
the peanut butter and jelly I definitely
have like a really hectic sugar rush
yeah Conchie unsalted butter with
raspberry jam oh my god hectic I love
that I know wait to us funny busy hectic
yeah what does it mean like you know
like a bit much but like in a good way
oh wait not a can great either way well
that's like the beauty I guess cuz it's
like neutral so like you could be saying
something like bad okay okay I'm gonna
start using that oh my god love